翻訳: Shiho Nakamura
校正: Kei Kamimura
皆さんは
何のために
働いていますか
皆さんにとって働く意味って
何ですか
学校を卒業して
これからは自立しなきゃと
会社に入って
早く仕事を覚えようと
朝から晩まで
がむしゃらに働いて
いろんな仕事がそのうちに
できるようになってきて
気づけば部下がいて
人間としても成長しようと
一生懸命努力し続けてきた
でもふと
俺って何のために働いているんだろう
そんなふうに思ったことは ありませんか
ある調査によると
72%の人が
働く意味を見失った
っていう経験があるそうです
そして みんな口をそろえて言うそうです
お金のためだけに働くのは嫌だ
もっと社会に貢献できていると
実感できる仕事がしたいと
でも現実問題 生活は大切
だから給料は減らせない
社会貢献は老後にだってできるし
稼いだお金で寄付することだってできる
だから今はやっぱり
一生懸命稼ぐことのほうが大切
そう分かっちゃいるんだけどやっぱり
なんだかモヤモヤしたものが
心のどこかに残っちゃってる
そんなことってありませんか
ここで皆さんに
ちょっと質問です
もしこんな問題が
皆さんの目の前にあったら
皆さんはどうしますか
日本に来た外国人が
部屋を貸してもらえない
外国人は
ルールを守らない うるさい
保証人が立てられない
いろんな理由で
外国人の入居拒否が起こっていました
さて皆さんなら
どうしますか
一緒に不動産屋をまわって
部屋探しを手伝ってあげますか？
人種差別だとどっかに訴えますか？
せっかく日本に来てくれた 外国人が
部屋を貸してもらえない
もう最悪ですよね
僕は頭に来て
だったら僕が
家賃保証するから
その上で僕が代わりに
大家さんの代わりに僕が
外国人の皆さんに
部屋を貸したら いいですよねと
そう大家さんに話をしました
そして留学生の人たちに
話を聞いてみると
みんなこう言いました
「日本人の友達が欲しい」と
確かにせっかく日本に来て
アパートに一人暮らしは
寂しいですよね
だから僕たちは
日本人と外国人が
半分半分で
一緒に暮らす
シェアハウスを作ることにしました
僕らがこの事業を始めた８年前は
シェアハウスという言葉すら
理解してもらえませんでしたが
今では東京都内に72ハウス
大阪と京都
そして韓国 台湾を合わせて
約120ハウスを運営しています
今まで47カ国
約4000人以上が
このシェアハウスに住み
同じ釜の飯を食い
一生の友人に出会い
今では単なる住居問題を超えた価値を
生み出しています
次にこんな問題に出会いました
ミャンマーの農家さんが
生活に苦しんでいる
この村はリンレイ村といって
約250世帯ほどが暮らす
ミャンマーの小さな村なんですか
農家さんのほとんどが
葉巻たばこの栽培をしてます
葉巻こういう葉巻たばこですね
で 葉巻たばこは
葉っぱに穴が空いちゃうと
商品価値が落ちちゃうので
みんな虫が付かないように
大量の農薬をまくんですね
だから農薬による健康被害も
たくさん起きています
農薬や肥料といった栽培コストは
どんどん上がっていくのに
買い取り金額は下がる一方なんです
仲買人からの
借金はかさむ一方で
生活は苦しく
タイに出稼ぎに行った15才の息子とは
連絡が取れない
そんな人たちもたくさんいました
村長をはじめ村の人たちはみんな
どうにかこの状況から抜け出したいと
強く願っていました
でもどうしたらいいか分からないと
さてみなさんならどうしますか？
僕達は葉巻たばこの代わりに
ハーブのオーガニック栽培を
提案しました
仲買人たちとも話をして
僕らが借金の立て替え払いをする代わりに
この村から手を引いてもらいました
村の一角に土地を借りて
ハーブのテスト栽培をして
どんな品種のハーブが
どのくらい収穫できるか確認しました
そして有機農法の専門家を採用して
村の人たちに
一からオーガニック栽培のやり方を
教えてきました
ほかにも
井戸を作ったり
収穫したハーブを
ドライして
カットしたりする工場も作りました
でも 問題はここからです
農家さんたちが作ってくれたハーブの
買取保証をするのですが
それをどうやって売るか
安売りはできません
彼らからの買い取り金額が安くなっちゃ
意味がないですから
でもそんなことより一番問題は
日本人はハーブティーなんか
誰も飲んじゃいないってことです
みなさんだって
コーヒーやお茶は
毎日飲んでると思うんですけど
ハーブティーなんか
誰も飲まないですよね
簡単に言うとマーケットが無い
さて困ったぞと
結論から言うと
僕らのこのハーブ事業は
2014年 年商8.4億円になりました
この5年間で88万人の
お客さんに使ってもらい
今までは年間30トン
リンレイ村約160世帯分相当の
ハーブを輸入するようになりました
さてどうやってやったのか
僕らは
妊娠中と 授乳中専用の
ハーブティーを作りました
この２年間は
カフェインを控えるのでお茶とかコーヒーは
飲まなくなるんですね
そして母乳不足といった
この時期ならではの悩みもありました
だから僕たちは日本の助産師さんと
イギリスのメディカルハーバリストに
協力をお願いして
そんなママ達のためのハーブティを
共同開発しました
こうやってできた ハーブティーは
妊婦さんや産後ママの間で
口コミでどんどん広がっていって
今では日本全国の産婦人科病院の
15%で配られるようになりました
昨年は楽天のショップオブザイヤーにも
選ばれました
さて最後の
問題です
アジア最貧国の１つと 呼ばれる
バングラデシュ
本当に貧しい人が
たくさんいます
彼らの力になりたい
でも 日本の約４割ほどの面積に
1億5000万人が暮らすこの国は
先ほどのミャンマーとは違い
十分な土地はありません
あらゆるところでお米が作られていて
米の生産量は世界４位です
それでもお米が足りなくて
輸入している
そんな中 水田を潰してハーブを作りましょう
とは言えませんよね
今度は土地がない
さてみなさんならどうしますか？
僕らが注目したのは牛です
イスラム教では年に２回
イードと呼ばれる儀牛祭があって
裕福な家庭では一家に一頭
牛を捧げるんですね
そして日頃肉を食べられないような
貧しい人たちにも分け与えるという
そんな事をやるんですけれども
１億５千万人いる国民の約９割が
イスラム教徒のバングラデシュでは
大勢の牛が捧げられます
もちろん食されるわけですけれども
そのあとに残る大量の牛皮
僕らはそこに注目しました
このバングラデシュにある資源
牛皮を使った製品工場を作って
貧しい人たちの雇用を作ろうと思いました
日本の革職人さんに
技術を教えてもらって
始めた自社工場は
2年間で300名を超える人たちを
雇用できるようになりました
今ご紹介したものはすべて
僕らの会社でやっている事業の一部です
日本、韓国、台湾
ミャンマー、バングラデシュ
世界５カ国７拠点で
約500人が働いています
ボランティアではありません
みんな仕事として
この社会問題に取り組んでいます
だから稼ぐことと
社会貢献は両立できる
そう僕は思っています
そして今みなさんに聴いていただいて
分かってもらったように
特別なことは何もしていません
問題を見つけて解決する という
どのマーケッターも当たり前にやっていることを
僕らは社会問題に対して
やっているだけなんです
だから正直に言います
このTEDxの登壇
僕はずっと断っていたんです
人前で話をするような
特別なことは何もしていないし
まだ何も成し遂げてない分際で
人前に出て偉そうに話をするなんて
なんか恥ずかしいじゃないですか
そんな恥さらし嫌だと
でもスタッフの方が
どうしても出ろと言うんです
困ったもんです しつこいんです
（笑）
みんな何のために働くのか
すごくモヤモヤしているから
あんたの話を聞かせたいと
でもそんなこと言ったら
僕だってずっとモヤモヤしてるんですね
でもモヤモヤしてるってことは
そこから抜け出したいっていう
証拠じゃないですか
何かやりたいことがあるっていう
ことだと思うんです
すごくいいこと
だからそのモヤモヤを
もっと大切にしないといけない
そしてそのモヤモヤに向かって
一歩を踏み出さないといけない
でもそうした瞬間多くの人がガチッと
固まっちゃうんです
お金を取るか
社会貢献を取るか
やりたいことを取るか
家族を取るか
何を選択するかで悩みだす
そして何も選択せずに終わる
そんな人をたくさん見ました
見てきました
でも全部やったらいいじゃないですか
「何かを選んで
何かをあきらめなければいけない」
そんなこと誰が言ったんですか
僕は全部できると思っています
だって全部やりたいじゃないですか
こんなこと言うと精神論みたいですが
これは精神論ではなくて事実なんです
全部やりたいという自分の事実
ここから目をそむけちゃいけない
あとはどうやったらできるかだけを
考えるんです
すぐに「難しい」と言うのは無しにしましょう
「一般的には」とか
「普通は」とか
言うのもやめましょう
それらは全部やらないための
言い訳探しにすぎないからです
変な枠に当てはめて考えるのも
やめましょう
「ビジネスは利潤を追求するものだ」
「社会貢献は儲からない」
「家族を取るか 仕事を取るか」
でもそれって本当ですか
今 話をしたように
ビジネスと社会貢献の
両立だってできるんです
僕バリバリ働いていますけども
朝も夜も一緒に家族とご飯 食べますよ
家族第一ですけど仕事も第一です
自分の人生なんですから
どっかの評論家みたいに
つまんない枠に当てはめて
話をそらすのはもうやめましょう
自分が本当にやりたいところに向かって
進んでいきましょう
でもそんなこと言うと
「そんな現実甘くないって」と
思うかもしれません
それあんたはできるかもしれんけど
やっぱり理想論やね と
確かに簡単なことではないのかもしれません
でも ここにいる誰も否定できない事実が
１つだけあります
それは 僕らは毎日
刻一刻と
死に向かって近づいて行っているという
事実です
僕が今ここで話している10分という時間は
間違いなく死に向かって近付いた
10分なんです
だから僕は
心の中のモヤモヤを
もっと大切にした方がいいと
本当に思うんです
だって モヤモヤを残したまま
後悔しながら死ぬのは嫌じゃないですか
僕は 「田口が生まれてきたから
この世の中少し良くなったね」
って言われて死にたいと思って います
だからこんなもんじゃ終われない
多くの人を助けたいと
多くの社会問題に貢献したいと
思っています
だからチマチマやってちゃいけない
最低でも１兆円ぐらいの規模で
やらないといけないと
本当に思ってます
だからどうしたらそれができるか
すごくモヤモヤしてます
僕という枠組みを超えないとダメだと
このままのスピードじゃダメだと思いました
だから会社のあり方も変えました
今ではこの会社には
たくさんの社長たちがいます
みんな「自分はこんな社会問題を解決したい」
という夢を持ってきて
この会社を利用してその夢を実現する
そんな社会起業家の
プラットフォームのような
会社に変えました
だから僕はたくさんいる社長の
一人になりました
そうやって僕たちは今
少しずつ大きなインパクトを生み始めました
世界の人たちを助けたいという
僕のビジョンは
僕という枠組みを
取り払った瞬間
一気に現実味を帯び始めました
だから形なんてどうだっていいんです
皆さんも変な枠組みに当てはめて
やらない言い訳をするのは
やめましょう
「難しい」と「できない」は
違うんです
難しくてもできなくはないんです
だから心の中のモヤモヤに向かって
一歩踏み出していきましょう
そして もし選択に迷ったら
よかったらこの言葉を思い出して下さい
「人生の価値は
何を得るかではなく何を残すかにある」
これは僕のモットーです
何でもかんでも得ようとするから
選択がややこしくなるんだと思います
でも人生は
何を得るかではないと思います
どうせ死んだら何も持っていけないんです
でも残してはいける
だから何を残すかが
人生の本当の価値だと思うんです
こうやって考えると
シンプルに
一歩踏み出せるんじゃないかなと思います
心の中にあるモヤモヤをお互い大切に
これからも頑張っていきましょう
そして私たち一人ひとりが素敵な
何かを残せるように頑張りましょう
私たち一人一人が
何かを一つずつ遺していければ
この社会はどんどん良くなっていきます
みんなでそんな素敵な社会を
作っていきましょう
ありがとうございました
（拍手）